roughly 500 years ago during the sengoku
period a boy named michikatsu tsugikuni
was born he had a twin brother yorichi
who was destined to be sent to a temple
when he turned 10 due to his odd
birthmark yurichi and michikatsu grew up
very differently yurichi being confined
to a small room separated from the rest
of the house and kept away from his
brother michikatsu who snuck behind
their father's back to see his brother
pity yorichi who was thought to be deaf
and clung to his mother's side whenever
michikatsu saw her at some point he gave
yurichi a flute he had made as a gift
around when michikatsu was seven he was
practicing sword swings while his
brother watched it was then that yurichi
spoke for the first time shocking
michikatsu however yurichi's declaration
of his goal to become a samurai like his
brother was dismissed as he would soon
be sent to a temple nonetheless yurichi
continued to watch michikatsu's training
and one day one of their father's men
offered to give yurichi some instruction
though he only showed yorishi a basic
stance the boy was able to land four
blows on the man this incident
bewildered michikatsu who had never
before landed a blow and he begged his
brother to teach him his secret to
michikatsu's disappointment mirici only
expressed his distaste for combat and
stated that he no longer wanted to
become a samurai once however yurichi
mentioned that before he took a stance
he breathed deeply examining his bone
alignment muscle contraction and blood
flow implying an early form of the sun
breathing style that yurichi would later
adopt this conversation caused
michikatsu to realize that for yurichi
the bodies of living things were
transparent causing him to pursue
mastery of the blade with renewed
intensity
before we continue any further we want
to thank raid shadow legends for
sponsoring this video if you've heard of
raid you know it's got a ton of
champions over 600 now but it's also got
a ton of badass bosses that fight in
totally unique ways let's take a look at
one now sir galaroth guardian of the
arcane keep unlike most of the other
bosses this dude is actually a pretty
nice guy he is guarding arcane potions
and he's checking to see if you are
worthy of getting your hands on them to
do that you've got to beat him up which
can be a little tricky his main mechanic
is in his basic attack it deals a ton of
extra damage to any champion without
buffs so your mission is to keep buffs
on your team at any cost seems easy but
it's complicated by the boss left minion
and trust me this guy is so annoying
raid's got a ton happening this month
with a fresh rotation of the brutal
hydra boss and a ton of events and
tournaments every single day including
some special valentine's day events
where you can get your hands on a brand
new legendary champion this is the best
time to get started and raid and if you
click my link in the description or scan
my qr code you'll get cool bonuses we're
talking a free epic champion vergas 200
000 silver one energy refill one xb
boost and one ancient shard so you can
summon awesome champions as soon as you
get in game the rewards will be waiting
for you here as michikatsu studied the
sword he felt envious of his brother who
he felt was squandering his natural
physical talent he also feared that now
that their father likely knew about
yurichi's immense potential their roles
would be swapped and he would be the
ones sent to the temple in yurichi's
place yurichi recognized this as well
the night that their mother finally
succumbed to her illness he came to
michikatsu's room at three in the
morning to tell his brother the news and
bid him farewell as he planned to leave
for the temple before their father could
make yurichi the family's new successor
yorichi expressed gratitude to his
brother and fondly held the flute that
michikatsu had given him earlier
michikatsu however was irritated
wondering how yurichi could treasure a
flute that couldn't even play in tune
and watched his brother depart while
saying nothing his jealousy of his
brother only grew when he read his
mother's diary following her death which
revealed that yurichi had known
everything about their mother's illness
and had planned accordingly from then on
michikatsu resented yurichi who he
realized to be not only physically
gifted but a genius as well he wished
for his brother's death and for the next
few years not hearing anything from him
he believed it to be true ten years
later michikatsu became a samurai and
married a woman who gave birth to two of
his children one night a demon attacked
his camp and left him the only survivor
but was quickly killed by urichi who
came to his rescue and apologized for
not being able to save his subordinates
seeing the object of his hatred again
and twisted by jealousy michikatsu
abandoned his family and became a demon
slayer to train with yurichi he saw his
brother attempt to teach the other demon
slayers his own breathing technique
without success regardless he altered
them to suit their own strength creating
the first breathing techniques
eventually michikatsu awakened a demon
slayer mark and developed a breathing
style derived from the sun breathing
known as the moon breathing despite this
accomplishment it left a bitter taste as
it was still not as powerful as
yurichi's own sun breathing as a demon
slayer michikatsu was often prideful in
the uniqueness of their generation but
was irritated by his brother's optimism
when he brought up the fact that the
bear had no successors in line for their
unique breathing styles the sun
breathing and moon breathing frustrated
from being unable to surpass his brother
as well as fearing the faded death of
those who awakened to their demon slayer
marks michikatsu was persuaded by muzan
kibutsuji and became a demon taking the
name kokushibo because he was also a
breathing user it took him three days to
fully transform into a demon eventually
he became the upper rank one of the
twelve kizuki remaining at that rank for
hundreds of years while his original
name was lost to history
sixty years after becoming a demon he
came face to face with yurichi for the
last time yurichi was devastated by his
decision to transform whereas kokushibo
became disgusted seeing his younger twin
now aged and decrepid as well as
infuriated upon realizing he defied the
fate of all marked demon slayers by
being far older than 25 years of age
seeing yurichi cry shocked kokushibo as
it was the first time he had shown
emotion in his presence confusing him
wishing to erase his human past he knew
he had to kill his younger brother
despite his old age and apparent
blindness yorishi's fighting stance in
preparation to strike frightened
kokushibo who realized that his immense
skill and power were still present
despite gripping his blade in
anticipation yurichi had already struck
and sliced across his neck kokushibo
became angry seeing his brother's
strength had not weakened in the
slightest and waited for a return strike
despite knowing it would certainly kill
him yurichi never had the chance to cut
kokushibo's head entirely off dying due
to old age while standing up at that
moment kokoshibo became truly furious
seeing that his continually excelling
brother had appeared before him having
transcended everything and died of old
age instead of losing a battle as well
as knowing that even muzon couldn't lay
a scratch on yurichi his one chance at a
fair battle is now gone and his brother
remains undefeated forever enraged by
the feeling of inferiority he slashed
orichi's body in half but inadvertently
broke the flute he gave him as a child
seeing that he still thought highly of
him even after his transformation
kokoshibo couldn't help but shed a tear
unable to truly sever his bond with his
brother he decided to keep the flute for
himself kokushibo was summoned to a
meeting of the upper ranks arriving
before all of his colleagues he silently
sat facing a wall only speaking when his
presence was acknowledged by the biwa
demon and revealing that muzon had
arrived muzon revealed the death of
gyutaro berating kokushibo and his
fellow upper ranks for being unable to
destroy the ubi yashiki family and
failing to find the blue spider lily
kokushibo admitted that he had nothing
to say in his defense as kagaya ubu
yashiki had cleverly hidden himself
after akaza brutally destroyed doma's
head kokushibo covertly sliced off the
former's hand stating he had gone too
far he explained to doma that he had not
interfered for his benefit but for the
preservation of the hierarchy of the
upper ranks system he then told the kaza
to arrange for a blood battle if he
wanted to take doma's position asking
him if he understood what he was being
told akasa acknowledged this fact
promising to kill the high-ranking upper
rank which kokoshibo wished him luck
before departing
during a meeting of the hashira
reporting the appearance of strange marx
amman ubu yashiki recalls that these
marks were common among a select few
users of the original breathing style
kokushibo having been one of those few
kagaku remembers his encounter with
kokushiba while engaging zanitsu then
kokoshibo overwhelmed him and he quickly
surrendered but he decided to give
kaigaku a second chance and offered him
a large amount of muzon's blood hoping
muzon would accept him so he could take
a place among the upper ranks kokoshibu
told the demon slayer to be grateful for
his gift but threatened to behead him
should he spill a drop following akaza's
death kokoshibo is seen alone murmuring
how akaza had abandoned his path to
reach further heights and how he had
failed to defeat kokushibo and
reprimanded him for how weak he is
shortly after moichiro tokito is
transported to the same room as
kokoshibo kokoshibo then comments you
came demon slayer for some reason you
seem familiar he then deduces that
moichiro is a descendant of a child he
left behind after becoming a demon he
also deduces that his human surname of
tsugikuni has died out over the
generations
after moichiro calms himself down and
performs various styles from the missed
breathing his demon slaying mark appears
kokoshibo then compliments how
accomplished moichiro is as a swordsman
at such a young age kokoshibo states
that it must be due to the powerful
blood he passed down although moichiro
dismisses such claims after some more
battling kokoshibo manages to cut off
moyeshiro's arm moishiro quickly
tightens his arm to stop the bleeding
greatly impressing kokoshibo however
moyuchiro is effortlessly defeated when
kokoshibo impales him with his own sword
kokoshibo then offers moyiichiro the
opportunity to become a demon and be of
use to that man
this discussion is however interrupted
by genya shooting his nichiren gun
kokushibo effortlessly avoids the
gunshot appearing behind genya and then
proceeding to cut off both his arms and
his torso in half commenting that hmm i
see you're the one who's been eating
demons huh however he realizes that
genya is unlike the other imitation
demon from 300 years ago and that the
way to kill him is the same way regular
demons are killed by chopping off their
head before he has the opportunity to do
this genya is saved by his brother
sanami after genya apologizes for
everything he's done to sanami kokoshibu
states
brothers and demon slayers that brings
back memories sanomi and kokoshibo then
begin their intense duel with kokoshibo
being slightly taken aback at the skill
of the wintashira however he retains his
composure and states that he wouldn't be
able to survive if his senses weren't
honed from long experience this goes on
for some time with kokoshipo even
stating that long ago in the sengoku era
he gained a lot of experience fighting
against a similarly strong wind shira
kokoshibo then gets a good enough cut on
sonomy stating that moving would lead to
his entrails spilling out sanomi
proceeds to laugh hysterically boasting
the fact that he had marechi blood
sonomy uses his abnormal body and
breathing skills to control his muscles
to coagulate the blood and stop the
bleeding as much as possible after some
struggling and kokoshibo showing glee at
the opportunity to fight such a skilled
swordsman he was about to deal a
finishing blow until giome the stone
hashira arrived kokoshiba was unable to
retain himself openly stating that he
admired guilleme's peak physical form
following an intense back and forth
battle guillaume reveals his trump card
he meant to save for muzon his demon
slaying mark kokoshibo then confirms
that he too has the demon-slaying mark
almost showing sympathy towards guillme
he reveals the caveat of the demon
slaying mark without exception the
marked ones die before they reach the
age of 25 stating that the mark reduces
life expectancy and that guillme should
be dead by the end of the night since
he's 27 years old after an existential
discussion of what it means to be a
demon slayer and a human kokoshibo
offers guillme an opportunity to become
a demon so he can survive and continue
to hone his craft the same way he has
giome outright rejects the offer and
states that kokoshibo stated one
falsehood there must have been someone
who lived past the age of 25 after
reviewing their mark kokoshibo then
appears to be somewhat shaken but the
two continue their intense battle after
sonomy manages to stitch his wound he
rejoins the fray as the two now face
kokoshibo in a two-on-one battle
kokoshibo notes with surprise the ease
with which they are able to cooperate
despite being users of two different
breaths the three of them continue their
battle until suddenly sonomy and giome
are cut by what appears to be an
elongated sword with three blades
extending from the sides two from one
side and one on the other
kokoshibu now appears to be completely
serious in his encounter angrily stating
you merely shredded my kimono not even
enough to kill an infant once i dispatch
you two the rest will proceed easily
implying that giome and sanomi are the
two most powerful demon slayers in the
current generation in the meantime
moyichiro manages to free himself from
the pillar with a little life left in
him he helps kenya by reattaching his
body and feeding him a clump of
kokoshibo's hair genya then feels power
he's never felt before but more
importantly appears to directly hear
muzon's voice asking kokoshibo how many
hashira he has defeated indicating that
muzon is likely still incapacitated by
the initial explosion and the blood
demon art tamayo performed on him the
battle then begins to pick up
kokoshibo's attacks increasing with both
intensity and frequency he is able to
sever two of tsunami's fingers and both
swordsmen are reduced to putting all of
their efforts into simply avoiding his
attacks right as it seems that sonomy is
about to lose moichiro rejoins the
battle saving the other hashira just in
time genya who is hiding from the battle
behind a wall recalls a conversation he
had with tandro about being the weakest
person in a battle and motivated by this
swallows a broken piece of kokoshibo's
blade in order to gain its abilities the
advantage seems to again shift to
kokoshipo but in an unexpected turn of
events giome is able to sever the upper
rank's right arm while morechiro stabs
him through the torso immobilizing him
while genya unleashes a barrage of
bullets on the demon using his gun which
he altered using his own cells in a
similar manner to the kokoshipo's sword
the bullets embedded into the demon's
flesh then erupt into trees completely
trapping him as giome and sanomi rush in
to finish him off the sensation disturbs
kokushibo who is reminded of an
encounter from 400 years ago in which
yoricci was able to land a hit on his
neck something that no one managed to
accomplish since then enraged by the
thought of being defeated kokoshibo
sprouts multiple blades from his body
and severely injures all demon slayers
still the four charge onwards undeterred
as moyechiro's blade turns red seemingly
seeing kokoshibo's organs genya
unleashes another blood demon art
rooting another tree in kokoshipo's back
while gyome lands a blow on kokoshibo's
head with his flail and sonomy rushes in
with his sword their weapons all begin
to turn red and struck with thoughts of
his brother kokoshibo marvels at how the
demon slayers who came after them have
risen up to surpass them however wonder
soon gives way to rage as kokoshibo's
head is cut off and to the horror of the
four demon slayers kokoshibo regrows it
kokoshibo begins to celebrate boasting
to himself that now he has conquered
death by beheading any attacks thrown at
him are now rendered meaningless however
his triumph gives way to disbelief when
he sees himself in the reflection of
sonomy's blade
his new form is monstrous with tusks and
spikes protruding from his head face and
back disgusted by his new appearance he
recalls his original motivation to be
the strongest samurai in the country and
wonders if the path he has taken is what
he really wanted while he reflects on
his motivations gyome is able to crush
his head with his flail again beheading
kokushibo the upper rank attempts to
regenerate but to his disbelief his
flesh begins to crumble away and he is
rendered unable to use his blood demon
art as a result of moichiro's red blade
stuck in his body as he falls to the
ground disintegrating he reflects
bitterly that he only wanted to be like
yorichi he realizes that the one thing
he wanted to forget so badly he can
remember vividly yurichi's face while
his life flashed before him he admits
that he abandoned everything and in the
end has achieved nothing by killing his
only remaining blood relative and
betraying his samurai code in his final
moments he questioned why he was ever
born calling to his brother for an
answer before fading away completely and
leaving only his broken flute behind
click on this video where we explain the
entire story of yorichi tsugikuni